[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs merci de nous retrouver pour
votre numéro
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
8 juin revivez l'ambiance du 19e siècle
aux petits moulins des vaux de cernay
dimanche 10 juin un pique nique vous
emmène à la rencontre des peintres
paysagistes avec des comédiens en
costumes un bal et des jeux d'autrefois
d'autrefois
laura les cas chargé de l'animation nous
donnera le programme de cette journée
voyage dans le temps aussi ce week end à
chevreuse les 9 et 10 juin embarqué dans
un vaisseau avec l'association des trous
bader un spectacle décalé où se mêlent
humour chant théâtre et musique
profitez-en pour aller à leur rencontre
de nos agriculteurs la ferme de grignon
organise ses journées portes ouvertes ce
week end
notre rendez-vous junior mélanie nous
donnera les différentes animations et ce
week-end à plaisir le festival escales
d'ailleurs vous emmène au tour du monde
rendez vous incontournable de la ville
qui réunit des jeux de la danse des
ateliers des déambulations et de la
musique
ça commence à 14 heures au château de
plaisir les concerts eux débutent à 17
heures avec un groupe latino il y aura
aussi du jazz et des musiques du monde
le vélo sous les feux de la rampe à
montigny le bretonneux la 15e édition de
la lentille si klose s'élancera ce
samedi 9 juin
les retardataires peuvent s'inscrire sur
place le jour même des parts au gymnase
pierre de coubertin
plusieurs parcours sont proposés le
responsable de l'événement était sur le
plateau du cetud sport cette semaine là
monde ici que c'est une randonnée à vélo
qui s'adresse aussi bien aux licenciés
de la fédération française de
cyclotourisme cyclisme mais aussi aux
non ils ont site pour justement
permettre à tout le monde y trouvait son
compte on propose trois parcours un
parcours de 100 km un autre deux cent
cinquante et un troisième de 200
[Musique]
un rendez-vous façon déjeuner sur
l'herbe ce dimanche 10 heures le petit
moulin des vaux de cernay vous propose
un pique-niqué en compagnie de peintres
paysagistes laura les cas charge de
l'animation au petit moulin nous a
rejoint bonjour bonjour alors ce pique
nique des peintres paysagistes c'est
vraiment pour plonger le visiteur au
coeur du 19e siècle exactement les
visiteurs à l'occasion de cette journée
auront là l'occasion de suivre les
sentiers empruntés par les peintres
paysagistes et sur leurs chemins croisés
les peintres peignant sur le motif est
aussi les personnages costumés qui à
travers des saynètes et théâtralisée
ferron tous revivre cette époque de
peintre ou donc aller les peintres les
aubert les auberges et les
excursionnistes avec procession de ses
paysages
alors quel type de ce n'est pas ce qu'on
pourra voir par exemple on aura
l'occasion de croiser mayrand guillet
donc l'aubergiste qui avait accueilli
les peintres dans son auberge on aura
aussi l'occasion de croiser un jeune
peintre achille qui rêvent de venir en
grande part entre paysagistes ou encore
les excursionnistes voilà de léon de
vache elle convient de comédiens qu'on
leur envoie un petit peu en surrégime
ajustements les aider
des images de l'édition précédente
combien de comédiens sont sont invités
alors cette année il y aura sept
comédiens et trois personnes en fait
accompagnateurs plus en fait donc bien
évidemment toutes les personnes
costumées en fait les membres de
l'association des peintres paysagistes
de peintre en vallée de chevreuse et
vernis deurne l'équipe qui essaiera
également costumés
alors les peintres paysagistes c'est
parce que ce lieu l'un des des vaux de
cernay était une source d'inspiration en
fait pour de nombreux artistes des très
nombreuses un artiste en fait on estime
que plus de 300 peintre sans passer par
les vaudes cerner à la deuxième moitié
du 19e siècle et plus de 800 peintres
dans la vallée de chevreuse a
effectivement beaucoup donc les vaux de
cernay
un peu comme barbizon a été le coin de
nature qui a inspiré des peintres mais a
dans les veaux de cerner les peintres
ont retrouvé vraiment concentré de
nature en plus il y avait il y avait de
l'eau donc une beauté du paysage qui les
a beaucoup inspiré le sous-bois les
grands chênes centenaires les cascades
les jeux de lumière tout ça ça allait là
que de cernay sera inspiré des très
nombreux peintres et ce dimanche donc on
l'a dit il y aura donc les personnages
aux costumes et les peintres des
saynètes mais aussi en balles et des
jeux oui tout à fait donc il y aura un
moment fort avec le bal qui est qui
était très appréciée l'année dernière
avec effectivement les danses anciennes
avec la musique authentique
donc ensuite également les jeux
d'autrefois pour les petits et les
grands
et même une petit espace
photo où on peut refaire un seul fille
de costumes et avec un costume d'époque
la mode de l'époque exactement donc bon
là on l'a dit il y avait déjà une
édition à l'année précédente
ce n'est pas la première fois vous
proposer ce rendez-vous vous avez senti
un réel engouement au niveau du public
et la compagnie aussi qu'ils voulaient
peut-être revenir
oui voilà qu'en plus c'est vrai qu'elle
a
les public a beaucoup apprécié en fait
les saynètes théâtralisée et la
compagnie même aussi était ravi en fait
d'investir ce site quand même magique
c'est vrai que la qualité de travail
d'acteur fabula était été remarquable
puisqu'en fait il propose une écriture
sur mesure dont nous avons vraiment
travaillé avec les sources historiques
et leur manière en fait de mettre en
valeur le patrimoine à travers à travers
du théâtre un proposant les saynètes en
fait avec vraiment un poétique même
féerique et avec même une petite touche
d'humour
c'était était vraiment bienvenue et nous
allons nous avons également la chance de
travailler avec une association très
investi sur le sujet donc fondée en 2006
2007 l'association des peintres vallée
de chevreuse qui était aussi là
costumés et propose donc les peintres
contemporains aujourd'hui qu'ils
peignent sur le motif et et font aussi
revivre cette époque avec les
explications sur les techniques
picturales et pour l'occasion aussi le
musée sera gratuit ans le petit le petit
moulin notamment ses huit siècles
d'histoire à découvrir au fait oui tout
à fait donc le musée sera on pourra
visiter le gratuitement donc la
muséographie qui est dédié aux paysages
des vaux de cernay donc
à travers trois histoires la conception
de ce paysage histoire géologique
explique en fait le cas au degré ce
paysage pittoresque on retrouve juste à
côté de moulins l'évolution du paysage
avec le patrimoine hydraulique
l'histoire du chêne solidaire de six
moulins dans le petit monde en fait
partie et bien évidemment la
représentation du paysage par les
peintres paysagistes donc le petit
moulin c'est une histoire effectivement
qui datent ya fort longtemps
d'après lui une première mention de ce
moulin en tant que mon art médiéval déjà
douze sont sept
lahire appartenant une partie aux moines
de l'abbaye de vaux de cernay et ensuite
elle obtiendra cette cette allure en
fait actuel plutôt au xvième siècle sera
vendue en tant que
bien national en fait pendant la
révolution et ce sera finalement le duc
de luynes qui va prendre la possession
est ensuite donc
le moulin va fonctionner en tant que
moulin aux fabricants de la farine
jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle
vers 1880 où du coup la révolution
industrielle va faire en sorte que les
grands moulins un plus plus efficace
comprendre le relevait le relais pendant
et donc du coup bien évidemment petit
moulin va être transformé en auberge
c'était également un rôle est
aujourd'hui en musée et en est
aujourd'hui un musée des sites
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup laura les
cadors on précise juste que l'entrée est
libre sans inscription il suffit juste
d'apporter son pique nique et tous les
renseignements sont à retrouver sur le
site internet si vous voulez voir plus
aux renseignements voilà pour pour le
pique nique de ce dimanche d'hiver merci
beaucoup laura ling
un autre voyage je propose et met à
plusieurs époques
cette fois qui de l'oeuf ou de la poule
est arrivé en premier ou quand les
poules auront elles des dents de
questions auxquelles les trous bader
vont tenter de répondre à bord de leur
vaisseau temporel l'association se
produit ce week end à chevreuse un
spectacle décalé qui mêle chants corps
par mon chant chorale et théâtre
[Musique]
l'ivoirien
des eagles à mozart en passant par queen
ou alain souchon un répertoire varié
pour un voyage dans le temps
les 50 choristes des trous bader vous
emmènent dans leur vaisseau temporel
petrobas d'air sont l'équipage et
accueille le public comme des passages
heures et l'idée c'est d'aller répondre
à deux questions fondamentales de
l'humanité qui de la poule ou de l'oeuf
est arrivé le premier
et puis une deuxième question quand les
poules auront elles des temps ce qu'on
veut faire c'est amuser le public s'est
partagé avec lui tout le plaisir qu'on a
monté le spectacle on part sur l'humour
il ajouté
mais
dans la conversation
et elle en riant
du rire et de la légèreté mais surtout
du théâtre du chant et de la musique
l'association créée en 2003 a écrit
elle-même 110e spectacle chaque membre
un rôle bien particulier
je suis dans les costumes je suis dans
le théâtre et mon rôle dans le spectacle
c'est capitaine du vaisseau
c'est lui qui va prendre les décisions
face aux difficultés du voyage donc lui
doit rester sérieux hélas pour moi
embarquement prévu les 9 et 10 juin à
chevreuse et si certains se sentent
l'âme créative la troupe cherche
toujours de nouveaux venus pour l'année
prochaine
[Musique]
amoureux des animaux et des produits
fermiers le rendez-vous des juniors et
pour vous mélanie cette semaine on se
rend dans une ferme à la fin de grignon
tous pris de plaisir à leurs sentiments
c'est le rendez vous annuel leur journée
portes ouvertes
huit heures sans interruption pour
découvrir les coulisses de
l'exploitation mais pas seulement
les équipes de la ferme ont prévu un
programme complet démonstration de
chiens de troupeaux des balades en poney
des balades en tracteur est même l'un
pirates de paille difficile de tout
citer c'est aussi l'intérêt de pouvoir
expliquer au public aux portes de deux
de ses grandes agglomérations qu'on en
ile de france il ya encore des
agriculteurs et nous notamment acquis
sommes ouverts et les gourmands ne sont
pas oubliés alors il ya aussi un marché
de producteurs avec 17 exposants de
produits traditionnels locaux la ferme
présentera aussi des produits issus des
lycées agricoles qu'elles vont en temps
normal dans sa boutique gourmaud et pour
cette journée portes ouvertes l'entrée
est libre
il n'y a pas d'inscription il n'y a que
la météo pour empêcher d'en profiter ce
week-end c'est un peu le week-end qui
fait me la vache salers et restaurants
oui oui du côté de la bergerie nationale
on s'intéresse à la vache entre
tradition et modernité
là aussi des animations sont prévues
pour les plus jeunes vous pourrez
déjeuner et goûter autour des produits
laitiers dont une assiette de fromages
qui a été concocté par ludovic bizot
c'est un fromage et il est aussi
meilleur ouvrier de france 2015 alors
difficile là aussi de tout citer la
programmation étant riche mais samedi et
dimanche il y aura de quoi donner envie
de devenir un vrai petit fermier
merci mélanie le rendez vous est donc
pris pour se régaler et on apprendre
plus sur les métiers de l'agriculture
on passe maintenant à notre agenda
première édition de la nuit du handicap
samedi 9 juin à versailles la
manifestation débutera dès l'après-midi
magie poésie théâtre karaoké et
différentes activités handisport un
événement convivial pour découvrir les
talents des personnes en situation de
handicap
nos repas sera en fête ce samedi
également thématique cette année sur le
cinéma est ce qu a dit m harry potter
musiques de films et spectacles feu et
lumières
rendez vous sur la place jacques riboud
et à quelques jours de la coupe du monde
les commerçants de la marque à lyon à
montigny le bretonneux vous propose des
animations sur le thème du football
magicien jeu et tirs au but de nombreux
cadeaux sont à gagner
mais c'est une loisirs est maintenant
terminé merci de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro et je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
[Musique]